he
Am încărcat bagajele. Ne pregătim de
drum.
Tare.
>> Danube Delta.
>> Danube Delta. Cel mai frumos loc de pe
pământ.
Am încărcat bagajele în București și am
pornit din nou spre Delta Dunării.
Aceeași rutină an de an, aceleași
pregătiri, aceleași drumuri și totuși de
fiecare dată o simțim ca pe prima
plecare pentru că Delta are ceva aparte,
ceva ce nu poate fi explicat, doar
trăit.
Mergeți la chiria la cât
>> mergem la deschiderea de pescuit. Da,
vrem și noi dacă
>> 1200 RON până la Chilia vechie.
>> De persoană.
>> De persoană, da. Plus.
Kilometrii au trecut unul după altul,
iar odată ajun și în Tulcea, am lăsat
barca la apă și am pornit către locurile
care ne cheamă mereu înapoi. Am intrat
pe canalul 36, poarta de intrare către o
lume diferită, o lume în care timpul
curge altfel. De acolo am ieșit pe
brațul Chilia, iar după ce am trecut de
Chilia veche, ne am continuat drumul pe
Cernovca, către locul care avea să ne
fie casă în următoarele zile. Blue
cochilia.
După drum, fiecare și a intrat în rol.
Claudiu s a ocupat de cea mai importantă
misiune a serii, grătarul. În timp ce
fumul începea să se ridice deasupra
apei, eu m am așezat la masa de lucru.
Fire noi pe mulinete, monturi pregătite
cu atenție și ultimele detalii puse la
punct pentru zilele de pescuit care
urmau. Pentru că în Delta Dunării
aventura nu începe atunci când lansezi
prima dată, ea începe din momentul în
care pleci de acasă, iar noi eram gata
să scriem un nou capitol.
Cum ar
Ce frumos, nu?
>> Ce frumos, bă, dimineața, bă, dimineața
pe râia. Bravo, mă! Bravo, mă, băiatul.
Ia să vedem ce ți place băiat dimineața.
Ia uite, fii atent cum po Deci și cu o
lansetă de spinning.
>> Auzi, eu aveam o vorbă în filmele
>> americane
>> noastre.
>> Am început dimineața cu un drill.
>> Am început dimineața. Vrei să încep așa?
Am început dimineață cu un drill.
>> Merge bine,
>> fii atent cică am început dimineața cu
un drill. O lansetă. Am luat o lansetă
de spinning. A l am scăpat, mă. Nu se
poate, frate.
L am scăpat, frate. Să fie mai frumos.
Unde te ai dus, mă? Te duci la verdeață
să i scoată pește lui taică să mă ce par
să fie mai frumos, mă? Bucurie e mai
frumoasă ca asta.
>> Păi da, bravo. Do la blocilia.
>> Bucurie e mai frumoasă ca asta. Ei, na,
contează acuma dimensiunea peste loc.
Contează mă
>> e frumos, mă, ciortanul.
>> Ă,
>> da, băi, merge diseară la grătar.
>> Ce poate fi, mă, mai frumos?
>> Am zis lui Elena pân disară face.
Hai, nu
>> stai mă barosanul, mă. La prima oră, mă,
nici cafeaua nu s a băut, mă. Ia uite l
ce frumos e.
>> S a încasat.
>> Ia l, mă.
>> Bravo, domnit. Iată l, mă.
>> Dă l încoa. Bravo.
>> Dă l încoa.
>> Bravo, nea Titi,
>> vrei să l sănătuiesc, să l pun la
frigider?
Ia l, mă.
>> Bă, dar ce frumos e la culoare,
>> băi. Dar zici că i sălbatic.
Da. Fă l în b. Hai, dă i.
Lăsăm un pic ploaia să treacă, ne
refugiem la bluia și revenem după după
terminarea furtunii astea că plouă
torențial. Ne a făcut suntem varză. Faci
că a trecut și prin astea impermeabile
ploaia asta.
>> El capitan.
>> Doamne ajută. Facem înapoi.
Ia uite, nea Titi face cu mâna
în loc să pescuiască.
Hai să vedem.
He.
Aici la concurs
pe Cernovka, la concursul Delta Carp
Challenge am prins crapi frumoși. Am
luat de 10, am luat de șase, de
sigur trebuie să țină pește mare. E o
ciată care ține pește mare. Aici avem o
adâncime perfectă. 7,5 m.
Exact așa să văța.
Iar și pește oia.
Te bagi exact în stuf, în locul ăla din
stuf,
>> în gaura aia. Da,
>> da, da.
Dar ce frumos arunc. Zici că toată viața
am fost aruncător.
Cobrat.
Ia uite, vă umbră toate astea.
Pregătim zona pentru mâine dimineață.
Facem nădirea de seară.
Ne întoarcem la Blu Kilia și mâine
dimineață la ora 5:00 suntem aici pe
loc. Gata să intrăm pe el.
Boilusul principal, atât de înădit cât
și de cârlig, reprezintă noua gamă
Boiless Claumar nuclear, dar nu putem să
neglijăm niciodată, mai ales în Delta
Dunării, boiles urile Burfood cu armă de
căpșuni, care știm că funcționează atât
atât de bine.
He.
După ploile care au fost,
apa a început să vină din ce în ce mai
neagră și să curgă din din ce în ce mai
repede. Trebuie să căutăm zone cu apă
mai mai bună pentru că cu siguranță va
veni din ce în ce mai rău și cu
siguranță peștere nu va mai răspunde pe
zona asta unde suntem noi acum pe
Cernovca.
Deci clar trebuie să ne relocăm.
Bam! Trecem.
Las setele, las setel, las setele.
>> Stai uș.
>> Ce facem, Claudiule?
>> Ce să facem? Dă i mai dreapta. Dă i
dreapta.
>> Dreapta. Să nu facem ca Titanicul.
Asta sălbăticie adevărată
pe urmele crapilor.
Stânga, stânga, stânga.
>> Nu prea mult, că i și aici ciudat.
>> E acolo.
Stânga, dreapta, dreapta, dreapta.
Ăsta pe unde l iau?
>> Pe mijloc.
>> Dreapta? Nu.
>> Da.
Așa.
Și acum dă i deja cu stânga.
>> Mamă,
>> nu mai și din față mai
>> Nu mai avem.
Avem
>> dreapta, dreapta, dreapta.
>> Capul, capul, capul, capul. Ușor acolo,
ușor, ușor, ușor, ușor, ușor,
ușor.
Ia lans în secțâ. Ia lanse.
>> Nu ne mai întoarcem pe partea asta. Clar
nu ne mai întoarce pe partea asta.
>> Păi nu
>> ce a
>> cum
>> ce i acolo?
Poți s o iei pe aici așa.
Ia uite ce rezistente sunt penurile
astea. Ia uite ce a căzut pe ele. Hai că
mai rup acuma dacă
ia.
>> Da, bă, distentă. Ce să
>> gata?
>> Ce
>> aproape.
>> Dai câtă poți. Dă în dreapta.
Am îngțit o muscă.
Da. Stop. Stop.
Neapărat trebuie să găsim o variantă. Să
ne întoarcem pe altă parte, că nu mai
vreau să mai trec prin toate astea.
Când scoses motorul de tot înapoi.
Ă,
>> ai scos motorul?
>> Păi da, dar
suntem nebune.
>> Măcar suntem nebune de apă. Da. Uite,
>> vezi? Apa e din ce în ce mai bună față
de unde amcat noi.
>> Ce e bine? Apa e din ce în ce mai bună.
Dar o întreb eu acum, nu aveam și altă
variantă pe unde s o luăm? Să nu trecem
pe aici?
>> Bineînțeles, pe drumul cel mai lung.
Dar nu ne gândeam că e așa
de îngust drumul acum, pentru că eu am
mai trecut pe drumul ăsta și n a fost
chiar așa. E stuf venit în în canal.
>> Ai trecut printr o toamnă sau primăvară
devreme? Da,
>> toamnă. Da.
>> Și tot cu barca asta.
Haide că se vede acum. Bă, tre să
>> lacul dracului.
Practic, de aici, de la lacul dracului,
mai avem puțin și ajungem la Eracle,
zona unde vrem noi să pescuim acum.
Ia uite. Uite, mă, apă. Uite apă.
>> Da.
Apă bună.
Apă bună. Claudiule.
>> Vezi că i apa mică rău.
>> Vede și el. Cred.
>> Vezi că i apa mică mică.
>> Da.
>> Câtă îți arată?
03 04
Așa.
În sfârșit trecem și de hopul acesta de
pecul Tracului. Am mers numai cu
motorul aproape
scos din apă.
Stai că o partea asta s la sete.
>> Asta i delta și frumusețea ei. De asta
îmi place.
Apă de 30 40 de cm.
Dar acum intrăm pe canal.
Se mai
adâncește puțin.
e
Așa peisaj, așa mâncare.
Doar peștele mai lipsesc.
>> Să trăiești, unchiule.
>> Bună ziua.
>> Cum e adâncimea pe lac? Putem să trecem
cu asta?
>> Nu prea.
>> De unde vreți să mergeți?
>> Să ieșim în
>> Cernovca Covca. Să tăiem lacul și
>> acolo între Merchei
>> acolo. Da,
>> acolo nu,
>> nu ă
>> asta. Ia se lasă.
>> Da,
>> așa ne am gândit și noi. Aia am făcut
cale întoarsă.
>> Da.
>> Bine, mulțumim frumos.
>> Deci cel mai cel mai sănătos e să ne
întoarcem înapoi pe dracului. Pe
dracului și pe magistral. Ieșiți înăți
>> care i ăla?
Ăla de am fost mai devreme
>> pe camerajor.
>> Ăla în gust
>> stația 11. Ăla în gust.
>> Mamă, e atâta
>> s a făcut atâta și sunt copaci căzuți.
Ne am chinuit când n am venit de
>> că nimeni nu mai bagă niciun le da.
>> Ce să fac?
>> Sănătatește. Ceva ați găsit la plase la
vintire.
>> Păi nu că abia le punem.
>> A, abia le puneți?
>> Azi e prima zi.
>> Da, da, da.
>> Am înțeles.
>> Hai că ieri am venit acasă.
>> Doamne ajută.
>> Doamne ajută. Multă sănătate.
>> Bine.
>> Dă i, dă i în față.
>> Bine, întinse.
>> Mulțumesc. Asta la lăsat de la cu apă.
Păi a
>> Deci
>> Deci înapoi pe ochiul dracului.
>> Da. Calcă mult astea.
>> Da, da, da.
>> Și nici nu prea crescut apa. Erau ani de
fost. Era cal.
>> Da, de aia nici nu prea iei pește pe
canal.
>> N a intrat.
Da, exact.
e
F
હ
Cu toate că pescuim cu boilies, pe trei
dintre cele șase lansete cu care
pescuim,
avem momitoare cu placă și pentru un
plus de atracție punem nadă nucleară.
Aroma mea preferată pentru Delta Dunării
și nu numai este varianta de mango
vrem să vedem și diferența dacă răspunde
mai repede la varianta cu momitor decât
la cea cu plumb normal, simplu.
Să
miș.
Bă, realizezi?
Deci are 5 7 10 la oră
dacă tai
ia l.
Hai bine Claud.
>> Ce ți am zis, bă? S a trezit Mihai.
Hm.
După cum te ai trezit, cum a venit să
vezi.
>> Am început dimineața cu un dr.
He.
Pe lângă faptul că apa este tulbure,
vine și mare are furt până acum.
Noi am nădit timp de trei zile.
Încă mai sperăm.
L am căutat peste tot pe canale în
principal, dar apa este foarte scăzută
și nu
se hrănește pe canale. Am fost pe racle,
era plin de somn,
am fost pe Suvez, am fost pe o grămadă
de canale și nimic.
Nivelul apei este foarte scăzut pentru
perioada asta și nu nu este pe canale.
Tot crapul este în Dunăre. Apa e scăzută
pe lacuri, pe canale.
Tot aici avem speranță. Mai avem
aproximativ 24 de ore. Mâine pe vremea
asta deja strângem și plecăm. Sperăm să
vă arătăm măcar o coadă de pește.
Cum să zic?
îmbrăcat
cum e îmbrăcat îmbrăcat mare.
Ziua cu alea de armată
>> balamul are. Nu,
>> mamă,
>> mai e.
Nu,
băga mi aștepat.
E Da,
nu,
e bine.
>> Dacă e foarte foarte mic. Da. Și ăsta.
Ia uite,
>> stai așa. Ia așa.
>> Ia uite.
>> E foarte mic. Exact ce ți am zis.
>> Ia uite l pe ăsta.
>> Ăsta e plătit. Ce? Caras. Ia uite l.
Cică foarte mic.
Uite filmează acolo.
>> Nuclear de la Claumar.
Deci
le le trecem pe toate pe nuclear. Așa ar
trebui ca să ne facem o
să tragem o concluzie corectă ar trebui
să le trecem pe toate pe nuclear. I uite
la
>> laf.
>> BF food trage, dar trage mic.
>> Bun,
trecem la nuclear.
H
Bra.
3 4 kg
ultima cu care mă
>> mai ultima
Ce mă ca și o poziție?
Aha.
Ia vezi, ia vezi
>> ce,
mă, era asta, mă. Hai,
>> bag o pentru ele.
>> Stai așa. Stai un pic. Lasă puțin o.
Lasă
ăsta
nu văd cum se comportă așa. Maga
bătut duce. Vrea să se ducă înș.
>> Da, da, da.
De burtă l ai dat. Ai mă A ba nu, ba nu.
st i firmă că are unde să se ducă
>> și
Ia vezi, mă,
>> mă.
>> Bine, Claudiu.
Bine, Claudiu.
>> Aveam și eu un partener odată care nu m
ajuta la Mincioc. Acum
stai stai asta
stânga dreapta. Partea să stăm.
>> Bravo.
>> Ce ai, mă?
>> Te duce să stau eu tot drillul afară
când pot să vin să ridic și să plec.
Bravo!
>> Ce ai, mă? Ești nebun? Am un minut, două
minute de când am aruncat o.
>> Ce și îmbrăcat?
Cum e
>> îmbrăcat? Îmbrăcat mare.
>> Da.
Ah mă gât.
>> Mai dă i drumul, mă Claudiule, mă, că
poți să le dai drumul aicea.
>> Ați?
>> Da.
>> Am luat o pe asta de aici.
>> Nu mai e. Nu mai e pe
>> nuclearul că am luat o pe asta de aici.
>> Ia ia dă dă.
E
este
>> este
>> fă ceva cu ăla.
>> Stai,
>> stai. Ține l un pic pe lângă barcă.
>> Da, acuma doi că l iau cu fractul.
>> Ține l un pic. Ține l un pic.
mă
>> ă
băgăm la
>> să
a dat în ești nebun.
>> Dar ne a dat în crăci.
Păi ea foarte bine că ne a dat că facem
a venit pe
>> Mihai ia ia minciugul, te rog.
Ce faci? Băgat
>> echipamentul folosit la această partidă
și în toate partidele mele de pescuit în
Delta Dunării, de pe barcă și de pe mal
este format din Pen Squadron. Iată acest
model Squadron ajuns la generația ara,
ce are o putere de lansare de până la
300 de g
și are o rezervă mare de putere, ceea ce
ne permite să controlăm peștele foarte
bine în timpul drillului
pentru că putem să l să tragem foarte
bine de el datorită rigidității pe care
o are pe primul
segment. al lansetei, dar
avantajul ei major o reprezintă
acest vârf foarte senzitiv. Vine
însoțită de două astfel de vârfuri
fabricate din fibră de sticlă plină,
unul medium și altul heavy, în funcție
de greutatea plumbului cu care pescuim.
Personal, am ales să folosesc vârful
medium pentru această perioadă, pentru o
sensibilitate mult mai mare și pentru un
semnal al trăsăturii mult mai rapid. Un
astfel de vârf ne conferă o siguranță
deplină în timpul drillului și iarăși un
aspect foarte important o reprezintă
faptul că în momentul în care sunt
valuri, datorită acestui vârf nu ne
țopăie. plumbul sau momitorul pe
substrat, acest vârf, preluând șocurile
acelea de mișcare a apei. Și ca
echipamentul să fie complet, muleta cu
care pescuiesc este Pentidal XT, o
muletă robustă pe care știți foarte bine
că o pescuiesc de mult timp pe lacuri,
dar o folosesc și în pescuitul în Delta
Dunării și pe Dunăre pentru că este o
monetă robustă. Este o metă ce rezistă
mult în timp. Are frână rapidă,
recuperare de aproximativ 1 m pe tură
completă de manivelă și ambele, atât
lanseta cât și mulineta beneficiază de
cinci ani garanție exclusiv prin clauar
pescar. Legat de firul monofilament pe
care l am folosit, vom vorbi ceva mai
târziu pentru că vrem să desființăm
acest mit legat de grosimea firului
monofilament pe linia principală.
Claudiu, am ajuns
și la sfârșitul partidei esteia, prima
noastră partidă în Delta Dunării și
prima pe anul acesta și prima noastră
partidă împreună. Spune ne tu, Claudiu,
hai să spunem oamenilor prin ce am
trecut zilele astea pentru că am avut o
grămadă de peripeți.
>> Păi, ca să facem așa un scurt rezumat
noi am venit ca să facem și niște teste,
să combatem niște mituri. Am auzit de
foarte multe ori acest mit conform
căruia firele mai subțiri pe tamburul
principal, firul principal pe tamburul
mulinetei ar influența în mod pozitiv.
Dacă este mai subțire, ar influența
trăsături mai multe.
Am Am combătut acest mit.
>> Da, treaba era oricum oarecum clară de
la început pentru că suntem în Delta
Dunării. Suntem pe fluviul Dunărea
practic. Da. Unde majoritatea zonelor
sunt pline de structuri și se știa încă
de la început că nu avem ce căuta cu
fire subțiri. Drept dovadici pe al
doilea canal pe care am fost pe canalul
Su. Da. După ce am plecat de pe Eracle
și am ajuns pe Suez, acolo ai văzut și
tu foarte clar, nu aveam cum să pescuim
cu 0,35.
>> Era impozit dacă dacă ți dădea ceva
lanseta aia.
>> Ideea este nu ți influențează în mod
pozitiv grosimea firului de pe tambur
nu ți influențează în mod pozitiv. Nu ai
mai multe trăsături dacă ai un fir mai
subțire pe tambur, deci mit devastat
>> pentru că am avut mai multe trăsături la
mulinetele cu fir de 0,45 de 0,45 mm și
am pentru că am avut trei lansete cu
0,35, trei cu 0,45 și am avut mai multe
trăsături la monetele cu 0,45, deci mit
combătut.
>> Da. De și asta pe o zonă cu deschidere
largă unde efectiv n avea puteam să dăm
acolo. Bine, mersi. Și cu 018
>> Da, da, da.
>> Stăteai un pic mai mult în drill, dar
scoteai crapii, deci nu era nicio
problemă. Dar drept dovadă nu
influențează. Ok, sunt oarecum am
verificat sunt statistici făcute că
ar influența oarecum, dar nu pe Dunăre.
Deci nu pe Dunăre, pe lacuri este foarte
posibil, dar nu pe fluviile mari precum
Dunărea sau eu știu alte râuri Ebro și
așa mai departe.
Nici pe lacuri.
>> Nici pe lacuri.
>> Bun. Ăsta este primul mit pe care l am
combătut, pe care am vrut să l dezbatem
și l am combătut în această partidă.
Ăsta este primul mit pe care am vrut să
l dezbatem și să l combatem. Iar un al
doilea mit, la fel de important ca
acesta, reprezintă mărimea cârligelor
folosite în Delta Dunării. Și vreau să
vă spun și să vă reamintesc faptul că
cârligele mici în Delta Dunării de nu
știu numărul șase, numărul opt în
pescuitul crapului
vă aduc numai dezavantaje pentru că uite
cum am demonstrat. Păi da, hai ca să
facem. Ai văzut? Eu, nefiind pescar de
băț, după cum bine știți, am avut o
curiozitate și l am întrebat pe Claudiu
în felul următor: cum de la Ontario ai
reușit să scoți crapi de peste 20 de kg
cu cârlig de iar aici noi am avut ceva
rateuri la cârligele de șase. Da, pentru
că am început pescuitul
cu câteva cârlige de șase și cu cârlige
de patru și de doi. După care am revenit
numai la cârlige de doi. Chiar și
ciortanii fiind, mă rog, nesim de 5 kg,
era necesar să petim cârlige de doi.
Deci, Claudiu
>> Aici trebuie să ți să ții mai în forță
peștii și ai nevoie să
>> Deci, facem o comparație cu bălțile.
>> Da. Da. Trebuie să ți iei mai în forță
peștii și nu poți să te joci atât de
mult cu frâna pe cât poți să te joci pe
un lac.
Pescuind
în deltă, nu știi niciodată ce poate să
fie pe substrat exact. Tu vezi pe sonar,
dar 100% nu vei ști niciodată
în ce se poate potigni crapul și de
aceea trebuie să faci drilul mai în
forță. Și de aceea am și scăpat cu
cârligele mai mici și trebuiesc cârlige
de patru sau de doi în pescuitul în
Delta Dunării și pe Dunăre.
>> Da. Și acum ajungem la o parte
interesantă în zona pe care am pescuit,
nu? Deci ce am făcut noi practic am
ajuns duminică seară
și planul nostru era să pescuim pe
tătarul.
>> Da,
>> dar tătarul fiind foarte de fapt n a
fost chiar atât de tulbure, însă era
mult mai tulbure decât era brațul
principal la
vremea respectivă, duminică. Și am ales
să ne întoarcem înapoi pe brațul
principal.
Am intrat pe Cernovca,
am găsit
o zonă foarte interesantă acolo pe
Cernovca.
Da. Unde
curentul întorcea puțin, ținea apa în
loc și
>> și un prag interesant cu crap pe el.
>> Da, un cra un prag interesant cu crap pe
el.
Ne am gândit noi să începem să nădim
acolo, deoarece și în zilele următoare,
când s a anunțat că vine apă tulbure
după Siret, ne gândeam că acolo ține un
pic de iarbă. Deci era o zonă pescuibilă
până la un anumit punct. Da, până nu
vorbim de apă cum deja
>> ciocolată.
>> Deja s a făcut ciocolată. Da.
>> Bun. Ce am făcut mai departe de acolo
după ce am nădit în acea seară? Păi,
locul acela a fost nădit în fiecare zi,
duminică, luni, marți, miercuri
și am am căutat după ce am nădit locul,
am căutat în după ce am nădit locul am
plecat în căutarea unor aperi mai
limpeze.
>> Păi da, dar de ce? Că luni dimineață,
teoretic, când s a dat drumul la pescuit
oficial se tulburase și Dunărea.
>> Da, exact. Da, se tulase și din
>> și am plecat în căutarea unor ape mai
limpez. Ne am dus pe Eracle, ne am dus
pe canal, pe Suez.
>> Acolo apa era bună, dar pe Eracle era
plin de somn.
>> Plin de somn, da.
>> Niciun crap,
nicio trăsătură. Pe Suez la fel, nicio
trăsătură. și
>> ape mici pentru că peștele
>> încă nu este pe canale în momentul de
față pentru că apa este mică și nu este
pe canale, lacurile sunt mici, încă nu a
intrat pe canale. Tot este încă pe
Dunăre.
>> Da. Deci majoritatea peștilor pe care i
am prins și pe care i am prins noi aveau
icre
>> de semn că virgulă crapul încă nu a
depus. Da. Și nu o spunem numai noi, o
spun absolut toți localnicii de pe aici
cu care ne am întâlnit.
Deci încă nu a depus. E A fost foarte
frig. După cum bine știți, în toată țara
a fost foarte frig.
Frigul s a prelungit anul ăsta. A venit
căldura târziu, iar capul încă nu a
depus. Deci probabil undeva până spre
sfârșitul lui iulie
>> totul să depună. Da, pentru că altfel ar
fi trebuit să găsim crapul pe canale. În
mod normal, la vremea asta crapul ar fi
trebuit să fie obligatoriu pe canale,
dar nu este. Apa este încă mică, nici nu
a intrat
pe lacul dracului. Apa avea 30 de cm.
Așa. După care ne am întors înapoi
>> printr o minune.
Am revenit la locul nădit la este un loc
pe care îl știam
>> printr o minune noroc căpitanul nostru
Mihai care ne a dus și ne a readus
înapoi prin locurile acelea nebune pe
care deja le ați și văzut.
>> Da.
Ne am oprit acolo și am
aruncat lansetele
în speranța unei trăsături. Să vedem
dacă se întâmplă ceva pe zona nădită. Și
au început trăsăturile. Multe la număr.
>> Multe la număr. Adică neașteptat.
Majoritatea locrurilor aici pe Chilia nu
s a prins. Ce informații am avut și
chiar pe zona aceea am reușit să
prindem.
>> Da.
>> Da. Deci
dar și o zi absolut nu știu
așa. Bun, să revenim. Furtună dimineață,
furtună seara, soare arzător, iar
ploaie, iar Deci
n am trăit așa ceva nici măcar la
untario.
>> Vremea foarte schimbătoare,
dar până la urmă am reușit să și testăm,
să dezbatem miturile pe care venisem să
le dezbatem.
>> Bine, nu în măsura în care am fi vrut
noi, pentru că am avut și puține zile la
dispoziție. Trei zile.
>> Da. Am mai fi stat, sincer să fi, am mai
fi stat vreo două zile în plus, dar nu
are sens. Peștele nu este pe canale, iar
apa este extraordinar de de maronie.
>> Și plus că plec la deschiderea
magazinului din Spania.
>> Da, plus că da, mai are și Claudiu timp
să se pregătească pentru noul magazin
Claumar Pescar care va fi deschis în
data de 13 iunie în Madrid.
Deci, practic, am avut o singură zi
productivă din toate cele patru în care
am avut 11 prezentări.
De aceea este bine să vii să stai mai
mult în Delta Dă pentru că nu știi câte
zile vor fi productive din toată șederea
ta.
>> Da, poate să fie prima, poate să fie
ultima, poate să fie
>> toate sau niciuna.
>> Toate sau niciuna. Asta este Delta.
>> Dar contează foarte mult să pescuiești
cu un boiless atractiv. Uite cum a fost
cazul de față. Cu toate că Dunărea a
fost neagră, am reușit să provocăm niște
trăsături datorită boiless urilor și
poziționate unde trebuie. Da, pot să zic
că și au făcut treaba cu brio, pentru
mine fiind exclusiv prima dată când am
încercat pe pe Dunăre
și ia să le încerc pentru că urmează să
plec pe o altă locație tot în această
lună și voi pescui exclusiv la nucleare
și bineînțeles tot anul
le vom
da de gust crapilor cu nucleare în Delta
Dunării pentru că vom mai veni Ne aflăm
la Brulul Cochilia alături de gaza
noastră Iulian Râmbu. Mulțumim pentru
găzduire și pe lângă cazarea
spectaculoasă pe care ne ai pus o la
dispoziție, spune ne te rog și câteva
locuri de pescuit, având în vedere apa
asta tulbure care a venit. Având în
vedere că apa nu este potrivită pentru
pescuitul la crap, în momentul de față
este foarte tulbure, recomandările
noastre sunt babilenă cenofilă sau chiar
canale din din împrejurimi. Apa este un
pic mai mai limpede.
>> Da, cu siguranță merită totuși încercat
Babina Cernovca. Ă, cu siguranță vom
încerca și canalele.
Anul trecut am fost aici la Delta Carp
Challenge și am văzut multe schimbări la
Blue Ochilia
din noiembrie până în prezent. Ce s au
modificat și ce se preconizează
să se mai schimbe aici la Bluokilia
pentru că văd schimbări majore
>> în fiecare an. În fiecare an aducem
foarte multe îmbunătățiri. Ă anul acesta
ne dorim să facem un spah, un spaah
frumos pentru pentru pescarii care ne
calcă pragul, un loc de joacă pentru
copilași, chiar și o zonă de sport. N aș
putea să spun o sală de sport pentru cei
care doresc să facă un pic de mișcare în
fiecare zi.
>> Pescarii, pe lângă faptul că se mișcă la
pescuit, trebuie să facă și sport ca să
facă mișcare pe lâng să se antreneze
pentru pescuit.
>> Da. Din din fericire pentru noi în
perioada proibiiții au fost foarte multe
familii cu copiii și ne dorim să facem
și un mic loc de joacă pentru copilași.
Atâta timp cât știi că copilul e
siguranță, tu poți să
>> să ți vezi liniștit de activitatea de
pescuit.
>> Exact. Exact. Exact. Exact. Îmbunătățiri
sunt tot timpul. Dacă stăm să analizăm
că locația noastră s a deschis acum mai
puțin de trei ani de zile, sunt lucruri
fabuloase care le vezi și tu de la lună
la lună în tot de la an
aducem tot felul de îmbunătățiri pentru
că ne dorim ca locația noastră să să fie
un punct de atracție pentru pescarii de
de deltă.
>> De deltă, da. și cu siguranță a devenit
într un timp foarte scurt Blue Ochilia
un punct de atracție pe harta pescarilor
de Delta Dunării. Până în octombrie,
când va fi concursul Delta Carp
Challenge, voi mai veni cu siguranță
aici la Bluokilia să mă antrenez pentru
concurs. Așa că ne vom mai revedea anul
acesta și nu uitați, dragilor, că în
luna octombrie va fi cel mai mare
concurs de pescuit din Delta Dunării
aici la Bluchilia Delta Carp Challenge.
Și anul ăsta va fi și o noutate. Băieții
scot la licitație un loc de pescuit, un
loc la acest concurs pentru a vă putea
lua la întrecere cu cei mai buni din
domeniu.
>> Exact. 7 11 octombrie, ține minte data.
Cei de la Bluokilia vor organiza o
licitație în cadrul căreia vei putea să
ți asiguri locul pentru a te putea duela
cu cei mai buni pescari ai momentului
din Delta Dunării.
Yeah.